[Musique]
plus de 150 millions de mètres cubes
d'eau jaillissant à ciel ouvert dans
paris chaque année de quoi alimenter en
eau potable la moitié de la population
[Musique]
ce ne sont pas les fontaines qui manque
dans paris on en dénombre 104 dont 74
sont les célèbres petites fontaines
vallat
[Musique]
mais ne nous y trompons pas cette eau
n'est pas de l'hôte sources c'est l'eau
du robinet l'eau trafic est l'hôte
source en plein paris c'est autre chose
il faut aller la chercher à 700 mètres
de profondeur dans une nappe dont la
capacité est difficile à évaluer
et il faudra ensuite conduire cette eau
à la surface on alimente ainsi une
fontaine
la seule vraie source de paris la
fontaine lamartine et deux piscines
[Musique]
chaque jour plus de 1000 personnes
viennent tirer 30 mètres cubes d'eau à
la fontaine lamartine alors que les
parisiens en consomment dans le même
temps un million de mètres cubes
[Musique]
m
d'où venez vous monsieur giovanni dans
lyon a moi j'habite à saint germain des
prés autrefois j'habitais à la porte
maillot je veux venir aussi et j'ai
toujours réussi toujours mieux chercher
de l'eau ici malgré que les gens des
cafés écouter voilà dix ans j'habitais
de le faire voilà dix ans que vient
chercher de l'eau ici j'ai mieux roulé
de neuilly oui vous tenez vous bien deux
fois par jour en pratique les jours va
chez taxi vient de temps en temps le
matin quand j'ai des petits tuyaux non
plus du tout maintenant est maintenant
non parce qu'on a mis trop loin mon ami
tu es là alors c'était facile bien plus
grandes loges avec ghazi khan je viens
les plus tôt vous venez d'où vient deux
fois par semaine j ai des x 2 x 2 x 3
enfin je m'arrange de venir avec
beaucoup de récipients pour venir qu'une
fois elle pourrait limiter un peu les
dévoyer h rien montré que la boîte hier
au mieux de montreuil vous venez tous
les jours alors on vient provient tous
les mois
[Applaudissements]
vous en prenez combien à chaque fois pas
de 12,8 à chaque fois environ litanie
delete vous faire moi quand le prêt on
économise qu'est ce que vous en faites
on le voit ça brûle
et vous venez comment de montreuil dans
le métro prend le métro puis aujourd'hui
le vélo d'un nouvel os mais saturn à ses
occupants ce bagage
[Applaudissements]
l'essieu avant
[Musique]
ils vont du viennent mais deux
personnages eux sont toujours là
le gardien de la fontaine 14 ans au
service de la seule source de paris et
le représentant du service des eaux
louis joue c'est qu'il vient d'après
vous chercher de l'eau en particulier
dormir un peu et prendre en premier lieu
les gens du quartier mais ceux qui ont
eu l'habitude de venir ici reviennent et
des gens qui viennent de l'eure paris
signe parce que leurs enfants ne
consomment que c'est aulas on va dire
s'il y avait des éleveurs de poissons et
japonais paris qui viennent chercher de
l'eau pour faire leur thé
nous découvrons ainsi un club au culte
des buveurs d'eau
[Applaudissements]
combien pour vos patrons elle est
produite delete parlent ils en boivent à
table à quel moment
oui au pendant l'heure du déjeuner qui
après
et l'heure du thé leur but est toujours
une bouteille dans le réfrigérateur
il ya un vrai show qui nous a mis de
voir la vérité il en aurait pas de
l'homme d'aujourd'hui je cherchais par
des amis quand ils viennent à la maison
sur fallout et ce qu'ils en pensent bah
ils trouvent ça bien meilleure que
l'autre taille mais quelquefois vous
n'avez plus vous partir en vacances est
ce que vous en emporter non seulement la
hanche
c'est à une source les environs face à
la finlande elle est en vacances de ski
étant un endroit où il ya une seule
grille mais leur accord formel habitants
de fermiers
et la forme miracle'
olivero x et pour les poissons après
bush et les meilleurs qui sont produits
à la perfection les choses dans le fond
de la beauté quelque part est un petit
peu de rouille vous savez ce les
manceaux turquie sont de créer louis
mais par excès ses copains c'est contre
le dauphin polaire avec des foulards
avez vous savez avec marc p dans l'un
d'eux dans la page avec le lot
binet et tapoter page était de l'eau 2
enfin voyons les ratés pour la chaîne
pour la ccam
c'est la seule eau qui permettent de
faire à t x et leur maximum en ville
les grands mères
pour le pompiste du point c'est aussi un
problème on lui demande de faire le pare
brise à l'autre sens certains prennent
l'eau de source au compte gouttes
d'autres ont d'un plus large appétit
combien de mètres cubes lisez vous par
semaine 700 mètres cubes environ on lots
combien de fois par semaine une fois par
semaine le la différence ne vous affolez
pas cet homme n'est pas un buveur d'eau
c'est le directeur de la piscine et bert
rue des fillettes
robert du mouty de vie dans cette finale
par les ressources le sont 34 cents
[Musique]
donc je prends la date précise
la nappe est assez importante et permet
d'ailleurs d'alimenter de la butte aux
cailles par exemple qui est alimentaire
est aussi en hausse
ainsi chaque année 200 milles parisien
se baignent dans de l'eau dessous vous
n'allez
oui tous envie d'aller le plus à l'aise
est-ce que vous avez vous vous baignez
dans l'autre non
[Musique]
non en fait
javellisée comme les autres officines
alors c'est très rare est perdu pour
tout le monde il y avait un moment donné
à voir un type qui devait dans la
piscine ils allaient puiser directement
à la sortie l'eau il endure et qui se
trouvait paraît-il très régénérer très
rajeunie après avoir vu cette boire de
l'eau de source à paris est un luxe qui
fait rêver et qui fait aussi de
nombreuses du place saint germain des
prés une habituée prend une eau qui
n'est que celle du robinet est pourtant
rue du dragon un mystère qu'entretient
madame la concierge du 14
est ce que c'est que ce prêt
c'est de l'eau c'est de l'eau vous avez
une hausse vestiaire nous l'autre sauf
vous avez d'autres sources dans les
moeurs tous saluent chose extrêmement
rare dans paris un amant mines
alors vous voyez monsieur ce que j'ai
ici j'ai des citrons dans l'année j'ai
quelquefois deux ou trois sites ont
messi ya beaucoup c'est beaucoup de
couleurs mais j'ai eu des citrons et en
ce moment aussi dans le fond de la cour
là bas j'ai une ligne du raisin qui
fournit environ 5 kg produits par jour
et combien elle milite comment elle
découle est passé on a fait des
méchantes il ils ont posé
ils ont creusé creusé pourquoi pour
rechercher son mais tata yoyo et
recevront leur maman l'aïd ont trouvé la
source
il ya combien de temps mais quatre ans 7
5 ans et depuis vous avez l'autre il y
avait toujours une autre source
on ne devient pas voir ça n'est pas calé
un puits comment est il celui vous
l'avez su comment alors je les ai pas
vus j'ai jeté un caillou dans mais je
n'ai pas vu de neige à 18 ans étaient
les plus calmes et détendus ça
profondément
oui relève encore que c'est tôt dans la
journée ce pareil pour moi
il assure ne pas tarie
alors des biens toute la rue du dragon
elle l autre chose pourquoi est nous
aussi on en aurait pas il n'y a pas que
nous donc leur dragon la rue du vieux
colombier
d'abord c'est ma fille ait travaillé et
nous savons c'est que l'autre vous en
parlez de vos envies d'aller en banlieux
n'en pense pas du tout on s'est regardé
ce que je donne mon sécrètement de la
renaissance il en tire écoles
[Musique]